[Musique]
samedi 7 mars 2009 à Couy un petit
village à quelques kilomètres de Bourges
dans le Cher
il est midi Luc Amblard et Guy Bordenave
prépare le déjeuner
ce samedi midi Luc et Guy donc qui
vivent dans leur type avion de Quick qui
sont ensemble depuis 20 ans invite
Marie-Laure la sœur de Guy à venir
déjeuner chez eux
[Musique]
à 16h Marie-Laure prend en congé
tous les trois prévoit de se revoir dans
la semaine
pourtant elle ne le sait pas encore mais
elle ne reverra plus jamais les deux
hommes
[Musique]
mardi 10 mars 3 jours après le déjeuner
Marie-Laure la sœur de Guy commence
sérieusement à s'inquiéter
depuis trois jours Marie-Laure n'a plus
aucune nouvelle ni de son frère ni du
compagnon de celui-ci et n'a aucune
nouvelle du couple et cette situation
n'est pas du tout normale
est très très proche de guy-bordenave
son frère ils ont des contacts très
fréquents il s'appelle tous les jours
plusieurs fois par jour même ils ont
vraiment un lien très fusionnelle
lorsqu'il appelle pas c'est elle qui
l'appelle et il se voit quasiment tous
les jours à titre personnel
Marie-Laure se fait du souci elle a beau
laisser des messages à son frère Guy ne
la rappelle pas
ce n'est pas possible qu'il soit parti
sans m'en avoir averti au préalable elle
se dit bon bah là j'appelle les
gendarmes et je leur explique la
situation donc elle les appelle et elle
leur dit voilà je n'ai plus de nouvelles
de guy-bordonnave et de lucambla je les
connais je sais que c'est pas du tout
leur façon d'agir et là je n'ai aucune
nouvelle est-ce que vous pouvez vous
déplacer jusqu'à leur domicile pour voir
s'il ne s'est rien passé et je vous
rejoins
une heure plus tard les hommes de la
gendarmerie de bogis sont les premiers à
se rendre au domicile du couple à
couilles Marie-Laure elle n'est pas
encore arrivé
à notre arrivée sur les lieux
l'habitation donc est fermée elle est
close
et on constate qu'il n'y a aucune
effraction sur les fenêtres qui sont qui
sont toutes fermées
les gendarmes frappent
mais le constat est sans appel la maison
est désertes
inquiet ils essaient alors de forcer la
porte d'entrée
mais le maréchal des logiciels Picot
décide lui de faire le tour de la maison
on décide donc d'entrer pour vérifier la
présence ou non des occupants alors
l'arrière de l'habitation il constate
qu'une porte-fenêtre est fermée mais non
verrouillée
[Musique]
on arrive donc à pousser légèrement
cette porte et à pénétrer dans la
cuisine
à l'intérieur il n'y a aucune trace de
vie et pourtant il y a un détail qui
interpelle les gendarmes
les radiateurs sont allumés
donc on se dit il y a eu une vie dans la
maison très récemment en tout cas
autre certitude la maison n'a pas été
visitée par des cambrioleurs
rien demandé que ce soit au niveau du
matériel hi-fi qui comme du matériel
fiscalité
on retrouve des bijoux on retrouve on
retrouve de l'argent d'ailleurs on
retrouve pas mal de choses et rien nous
laisse penser que tu peux s'agir d'un
cambriolage
c'est à ce moment là que la sœur de Guy
Marie-Laure arrive et un élément a
priori anodin va beaucoup l'inquiéter
[Musique]
on a effectivement cet tartine de pain
qui sont posés à même la table et puis
on a par ailleurs une bouteille d'alcool
vide et un verre brisé à côté
[Musique]
effectivement la première chose qu'il
l'interpellait c'est le désordre un
petit peu dans la maison puisque ce
n'est pas du tout le style de Guy et de
Luc c'est à dire que jamais ne sortait
sans avoir fait la vaisselle ranger
leurs petites affaires ce qui n'était
pas le cas donc par rapport aux
habitudes de Guy Luke quelque chose ne
colle pas
plus inquiétant encore au même moment
dans la chambre du couple quelque chose
attire l'attention des gendarmes
[Musique]
il tombe sur une trace rougeâtre sur une
taie d'oreiller donc il se disent
qu'elle pourrait être éventuellement du
sang mais c'est une tâche qui est sur
une surface relativement minime
s'agit-il du sang de l'un des deux
hommes l'oreiller et prélevé pour être
analysé
[Musique]
et ce n'est pas tout c'est dans la salle
de bain qu'un autre élément va
particulièrement alerter Marie-Laure
[Musique]
elle fait une découverte qui l'inquiète
c'est la trousse d'insuline de Luc
Amblard faut savoir que lucamblard est
diabétique et donc il a besoin de son
insuline et de s'injecter cette dose
d'insuline plusieurs fois par jour sa
vie en dépend Marie lambredenave nous
dit nous dit réellement qu'il ne se
déplace jamais mais jamais sans cette
trousse s'il n'avait pris avec aucune
seule chose ça aurait été cette trousse
d'insuline
les enquêteurs se disent à ce moment-là
que ils sont pas face à un cambriolage
ou quelque chose qui aurait mal tourné
il s'aperçoivent nécessairement que s'il
y a eu un départ il a forcément été
précipité on a du mal à comprendre dans
quelles conditions et donc on n'a pas
l'impression que on ait eu un départ qui
était programmé en tout cas les deux
hommes seraient donc partie dans
l'urgence mais dans ce cas pourquoi
d'autant que quelque chose ne colle pas
la Mercedes est toujours dans le garage
[Musique]
il est difficile d'imaginer que les deux
hommes aient pu partir sans leur voiture
de leur domicile donc c'est quand même
un point particulier une disparition de
personnes mais leur véhicule est quand
même dans le garage
dès lors les gendarmes envisagent
plusieurs pistes
les gendarmes même s'il y a peu
d'éléments sur place laissant penser par
exemple à une scène de crime se disent
quand même que cette disparition est
inquiétante et les gendarmes vont
rapidement prendre cette histoire au
sérieux
les enquêteurs tentent alors de fouiller
la vie du couple pour peut-être trouver
des indices qui pourraient les aider et
une chose est sûre dans le petit village
de couilles Guy et Luc ne passent pas
inaperçu c'est vrai qu'ils ont une belle
voiture il roulent en Mercedes et ils
ont souvent beaucoup d'argent liquides
sur eux d'abord ils aiment les bonnes
tables ils aiment les sorties ils aiment
changer régulièrement de voiture ils
aiment partir en vacances et autant que
possible en profiter un maximum dès
qu'ils ont de l'argent ça leur file
entre les mains rien épargné tout
dépensé les deux hommes semblent mener
grand train peut-être de quoi susciter
des convoitises
alors les gendarmes s'intéressent à la
vie professionnelle du couple
[Musique]
sont des producteurs de spectacles et
sont notamment propriétaire d'une
société qui s'appelle le Burj gala bon
je gala effectivement travaille dans
tous les domaines du spectacle ça va
aller du karaoké au spectacle
d'animation dans un supermarché au
spectacle pour les collectivités type
spectacle de fin d'année ce n'est pas
une grande structure c'est une petite
entreprise qui vivote localement au
niveau des recettes Bourges gala un
petit peu de l'aile et on a le sentiment
que le couple flambe peut-être un peu
plus qu'il ne devrait les enquêteurs
sont surpris ces faibles revenus ne
coïncident pas du tout avec le train de
vie du couple
les enquêteurs va donc tout
naturellement procéder à des
investigations sur le fonctionnement de
cette société et les éventuelles
anomalies ou les éventuelles éléments
qui attiraient leur attention
et ses investigations vont révéler une
très grosse surprise sur l'un des deux
disparus
monsieur blanc n'est pas inconnu de la
justice
il a même fait de la prison alors on
sait pas très bien pourquoi pour des
escroqueries des arnaques à la TVA on ne
sait pas très bien
les enquêteurs s'interrogent se passer
trouble serait-il la cause de la
disparition du couple les deux hommes se
serait-il fait des ennemis
les enquêteurs vont penser à l'hypothèse
d'un règlement de compte dans le cadre
professionnels font un certain nombre de
vérifications sur cette hypothèse là
mais cette piste ne donnerait
les enquêteurs imaginent alors une autre
hypothèse la menace d'un règlement de
compte les auraient-elles poussées à
fuir
[Musique]
peut-être que de par se passer de par un
certain nombre de personnes qui
pourraient leur en vouloir le couple a
pris peur pour une raison que les
gendarmes à ce moment-là ignorent et
qu'il a voulu disparaître le plus
rapidement possible et si jamais Guy et
Luke se sont enfuis il y a un moyen très
simple de retrouver leur trace
pour tenter de savoir où sont partis Luc
Amblard et guy-bordenave les enquêteurs
disposent de Mouchard leur téléphone
portable le gendarmes se disent on va
essayer d'analyser leur communication
téléphonique de voir si ce sont servis
de leur téléphone portable depuis le
samedi 16h dernier heure à laquelle ils
ont été vus vivants et on s'est aperçu
que les derniers appels que ce soit au
domicile ou sur les lignes portables
remonter au samedi en fin d'après-midi
Guy et Luc n'ont plus donné signe de vie
après le déjeuner avec Marie-laure
qu'a-t-il pu se passer ensuite pour le
savoir cette fois c'est dans les relevés
bancaires du couple que les gendarmes
vont se plonger et donc il va y avoir
des investigations qui vont être
réalisées et on va se rendre compte
qu'il y a deux retraits qui vont être
effectués le dimanche soir
Luc gamblard a utilisé sa carte à 20h
puis à 20h15
il a même tenté de l'utiliser une
troisième fois mais sa carte a été
avalée par le distributeur
à retiré donc des grosses sommes 500
euros et 400 euros en laissant le compte
complètement vide
peut-être le couple a voulu retirer un
maximum d'argent pour disparaître
mais surtout il y a une chose qui
interpelle les enquêteurs ses retraits
n'ont pas été effectués dans le Cher
mais à 200 km du domicile du couple
à Paris
seulement problème le distributeur de
billets n'est pas équipé en vidéo
surveillance
rien ne permet de savoir s'il s'agit du
camblar lui-même qu'utilise sa carte si
c'est guy-bordonna ou si c'est une autre
personne qui aurait eu en possession la
carte et le code puisque le code lui
était nécessaire cela fait maintenant 4
jours que Luc Amblard et guy-bordenave
n'ont plus donné aucun signe de vie
heureusement un tout nouveau témoignage
va donner une première piste aux
enquêteurs
jeudi 12 mars les gendarmes reprennent
le porte-à-porte dans le village de
couilles et un homme va leur fournir une
information capitale on apprend par le
voisin le plus proche du couple qu'il se
trouvait à rentrer chez lui dans la nuit
du samedi au dimanche aux environs de 2h
du matin et quand il est arrivé à son
domicile il a constaté de la lumière
dans le domicile de ses voisins
ça m'a étonné parce qu'il se couche de
bonheur en général ça ne correspond pas
à leurs habitudes de vie
et cette lumière au milieu de la nuit
n'est pas le seul élément qui a intrigué
le voisin ce qu'il a un peu plus
intrigué c'est la présence d'un fourgon
blanc devant la maison
[Musique]
je n'avais jamais vu ce fourgon blanc je
ne peux pas vous donner de
renseignements sur l'immatriculation du
véhicule
sur le coup effectivement le voisin de
notre pas la plaque d'immatriculation
puisqu'il n'y a rien qui lui pose
question mais par contre le lendemain il
dit tiens je vais regarder ce que le
camion blanc que j'ai vu la veille est
toujours là et à ce moment-là cette
fois-connaise blanche a disparu qui sont
ces visiteurs mystérieux qui étaient
présents chez Guy et Luc le soir de leur
disparition les gendarmes ont peut-être
une idée une phrase dans la déposition
du voisin attire leur attention
j'ai remarqué la présence de deux
ouvriers qui travaillaient sur la maison
depuis 15 jours et notamment le fameux
samedi matin
[Musique]
le samedi matin encore il travaillait
sur le chantier puisque le pavillon
n'est pas complètement fini assez
logiquement les gendarmes vont entendre
ces deux ouvriers là ils avaient accès à
la maison ils avaient accès donc aux
personnes qui qui habitent donc que nous
n'avons pas exclu la possibilité donc
d'une éventuelle implication par
ailleurs le four Gon blanc qui a été
aperçu devant la maison était un
véhicule utilitaire les enquêteurs
émettent alors une hypothèse
attirée par le train de vie du couple
les deux ouvriers ont-ils agressé Luc en
bla Reggie Bordenave
dans les heures qui suivent les
gendarmes décident d'interroger les deux
ouvriers
on procédera également sur ces personnes
à des relevés d'empreintes mais
également à des prélèvements ADN en vue
d'une éventuelle comparaison par la
suite les deux ouvriers ni tout
implication
ils affirment d'ailleurs s'être présenté
le lundi et avoir été surpris de trouver
porte close
disent aux gendarmes que en réalité il
n'y avait aucun intérêt à tuer ces deux
personnes puisque le chantier n'était
pas fini et qu'ils n'ont toujours pas
été payés et ce n'est pas le seul
élément qui innocente les deux hommes
l'utilitaire des ouvriers n'est ni de la
couleur ni du modèle qui a été aperçu le
samedi soir cette piste abandonnée
légendes doivent reprendre l'enquête à
zéro il décide alors de déployer les
très grands moyens
[Musique]
deux hommes vivant en couple dans un
petit village du Cher près de Bourges
ont toujours porté disparus ce soir et
cela depuis 6 jours vendredi 13 mars les
forces de l'ordre décident de faire
appel à la presse pour lancer un avis de
recherche les proches du couple tentent
alors de sensibiliser l'opinion publique
parmi eux le neveu de guy-bordonnave on
sait pas si ils sont vivants alors on
essaie de
c'est un couple sans histoire sans
histoire carrément sont là pour aider
tout le monde et c'est pas si c'est pas
c'est franchement aucune mauvaise
fréquentation c'était des gens adorables
en parallèle 50 gendarmes sont déployés
dans l'ensemble du département du Cher
pour retrouver la trace du couple de
Quick
à partir de ce moment donc on met tout
en œuvre autant que de retrouver ces
personnes on utilise donc un hélicoptère
des chiens
des plongeurs des militaires donc à pied
qui font des battus dans les forêts
autour des points d'eau
[Musique]
cette campagne de recherche ne va pas
porter ses fruits c'est un petit peu
chercher l'aiguille dans la meule de
foin les gendarmes ne savent pas
exactement par où partir donc il lance
des recherches tous azimut mais sans
savoir exactement où chercher bien
évidemment il n'y a toujours aucune
trace des deux hommes
aucune trace des deux hommes mais un
élément va attirer l'attention des
gendarmes
[Musique]
sur la commune de bouleraie qui est donc
assez assez éloigné de couilles sont
retrouvés dans un fossé enfin en bordure
de en bordure de route différents en
fragments des morceaux de morceaux de
papier qui ont vraisemblablement été
déchirée qui appartiennent ces papiers
d'identité
un seul moyen de le savoir
à ce moment là les gendarmes ont
effectué un travail minutieux de
recomposition de ces documents là qui
sont vraiment émiettés qui sont en
centaines de petits morceaux les
gendarmes vont reconstituer le puzzle
les numéros
identifiés vont nous permettre de
déterminer qu'il s'agit d'un morceau du
permis de conduire de Monsieur Bordenave
il découvre également des documents
bancaires et un chien qui est au nom du
couple à partir de là les gendarmes se
disent quelque chose cloche on sait tout
de suite poser la question donc de
savoir
pour quelle raison ces papiers avaient
été retrouvés donc à 60 km du domicile
de ces personnes qui les avaient déposé
là et pourquoi les avoir déchirés
pour les gendarmes la piste criminelle
se confirme peu à peu
il décide alors de retourner au pavillon
de couilles pour passer la maison des
disparus au peigne fin et ce qu'ils vont
y découvrir et tout simplement horrible
dès le lendemain une équipe scientifique
investit la maison de Quick notamment
pour rechercher d'éventuelles traces de
sang qui auraient été nettoyées par les
agresseurs pour cela les enquêteurs ont
une solution le Blue Star
le booster donc c'est un produit qui va
nous permettre de révéler des tâches de
sang qui ont été soit essuyées ou laver
il passe donc l'intérieur du pavillon au
peigne fin le principe du blues star est
simple là où il y a des tâches bleues
fluo c'est que du sang a été nettoyé
et il ne faut que quelques instants pour
que le produit réagisse
et assez rapidement les gendarmes se
rendent compte qu'effectivement il n'y
avait pas qu'une seule petite trace de
sang comme il l'avait découvert la
première fois mais bien une myriade de
tâches de sang que certains semblent
avoir voulu effacer on a des traces de
sang dans presque toute la maison
mais c'est dans le salon à côté de la
cheminée que la réaction au liquide et
la plus forte
une tâche de sang assez importante au
niveau de la cheminée va être donc
révélée ce qui laisse à penser que il y
aurait eu bel et bien lu tout au moins
un ou plusieurs coups donnés à une ou
plusieurs personnes et les gendarmes se
disent quelque chose de grave c'est
passé que ce flot de sang doit
correspondre à des blessures importantes
reste à savoir à qui appartient ce sang
le sang qui était retrouvé dans les
différentes pièces et le même que celui
qui avait été retrouvé la première fois
au niveau de la taie d'oreiller il
s'agit du sang de guy-bordenave
la maison de couilles semble avoir été
le théâtre d'une scène particulièrement
violente
on a commencé à se dire
est-ce qu'ils sont est-ce qu'ils sont
encore vivants
dimanche 15 mars cela fait une semaine
que l'on est toujours sans nouvelles de
guy-bordena velucks
ce matin-là Marie-Laure la sœur de Guy
appelle les gendarmes
elle a quelque chose alors raconté et
cela concerne son ex-compagnon
un certain Claude juillet
[Musique]
on dit ex-compagnon mais Marie-Laure
bordena avec Claude juillet continue
d'entretenir des rapports intimes et des
rapports entre eux ils s'entendent bien
il y a pas de disputes ou de conflit
entre eux alors que l'on soupçonne le
pire elle se souvient d'un détail qui va
avoir son importance par la suite
Marie-Laure raconte au gendarmes à voir
reçu la visite de Claude juillet c'était
le lundi suivant la disparition de son
frère et un événement la perturbée
sont chez Marie-Laure ils viennent de
finir de dîner Claude juillet prend son
portefeuille pour noter des choses sur
sur des papiers comme il a l'habitude de
faire et il va laisser tomber de manière
complètement fortuite de cartes bancaire
juillet fait tomber devant elle de carte
bancaire et elle a juste le temps de
voir sur l'une d'entre elles inscrit le
nom de la société Burj gala
pourquoi Claude juillet son ex-compagnon
détiendrait-il la carte bleue de la
société de Guy et Luc
interrogé par Marie-Laure il aurait
tenté de la rassurer mais lui il manque
quelques mots très brièvement va lui
dire non mais c'est rien
tu n'as rien vu c'est pas ça tu t'es
trompé
elle ne surenchérit pas et la
conversation est terminée
dès lors les soupçons vont légitimement
porter sur Claude juillet et le fait
qu'il est en sa possession l'écart de la
société Claude juillet aurait-il un lien
avec la disparition de Guy et Luc où
a-t-il simplement volé leur carte
bancaire
l'homme va devoir s'expliquer
dimanche 15 mars les gendarmes se
rendent au domicile de Claude juillet
les enquêteurs notent sa déposition il a
53 ans il est intermittent du spectacle
et dans le passé il a été employé par
Burj gala sur différentes animations il
explique qu'il est lui aussi très
inquiet de la disparition de Guy eluke
notamment sur son emploi du temps de la
nuit du samedi au dimanche et nous
explique que en fait il est resté à son
domicile qu'il a regardé des DVD à la
télé et qui s'est couché normalement
qu'il a pas bougé de chez lui
les gendarmes décident alors de
perquisitionner son domicile
on cherche le petit indice qui nous
permettrait de relier Claude juillet et
les deux disparus ça peut être des
photos ça peut être des clés ça peut
être enfin tout et n'importe quoi et
rapidement les gendarmes vont faire une
première découverte très intéressante
mais dans le code de cette perquisition
on retrouvera une grande quantité
d'armes en tout genre des sabres des
arbalettes des armes de poing des fusils
juillet bon reste de marbre il répond
bon c'est de la décoration tu vois ça
pas forcément mais que c'est pour
décorer la maison
mais en continuant leur perquisition les
enquêteurs vont aller de surprise en
surprise
nous continuons donc la visite de du
domicile de Monsieur juillet et nous
constatons bizarrement la présence dans
ce garage d'un fond blanc ils sont
surpris vu ce qu'ils vont penser en fait
à ce que leur a dit le voisin de
lucamblard et Guy Bordenave c'est que la
nuit du 7 mars il a vu un fourgon blanc
du même type devant la maison du couple
est-ce une simple coïncidence
quand les gendarmes fouillent le
véhicule il n'y a plus de doute possible
nous allons découvrir dans le vide poche
conducteur donc du véhicule de Monsieur
juillet nous allons découvrir un
porte-clé et ça verra par la suite que
se trouve cette clé ouvre le domicile de
Luc Amblard et de novembre
les gendarmes n'en reviennent pas et la
perquisition n'est pas encore fini
le protocole veut que nous faisions
également donc tout ce qui est poubelles
contenait à poubelles dans la cour de
l'habitation on constate la présence
d'une poubelle on ouvre ses poubelles et
simplement au fond de cette poubelle on
retrouve des colliers de serrage de type
serflex
dont certains ont été découpés donc la
présence de cfflexe donc nous
immédiatement interpellé il est vrai que
on peut utiliser ce type d'objets donc
dans plusieurs domaines le jardinage
mais aussi pour me noter quelqu'un
grâce aux indices recueillis cela ne
fait plus de doutes Claude juillet et
mêlé à la disparition de Luc en blareg
guy-bordenave
[Musique]
mais de quelle manière
Claude juillet est mis en garde à vue
parallèlement à son interrogatoire les
enquêteurs vont tenter d'en savoir plus
sur son passé aider les premières
vérifications ils vont se rendre compte
qu'il n'a rien d'un enfant de cœur
et il se trouve que Claude juillet a eu
affaire à la justice par le passé pour
des braquages d'abord des braquages des
vols à main armés en région parisienne
20 ans auparavant quand il était jeune
la sanction a même été lourde Claude
juillet a passé 8 années en prison
pourtant difficile d'en tirer la moindre
conclusion les enquêteurs se rendent
compte que son rôle était en fait
extrêmement mineur
dans le cadre de ses braquages qui
étaient commis à 4 ou 5 personnes lui
faisait le chauffeur c'est à dire que il
n'a jamais été violent dans le cadre de
ce braquage il a jamais été avec les
armes lui-même c'est-à-dire qu'il voilà
il est resté dans la voiture et il
faisait le chauffeur
à plus de 20 ans et pendant 20 ans il a
jamais fait parler lui quoi donc pour
nous enfin c'est un point
supplémentaire mais c'est pas un point
suffisant
d'ailleurs Claude juillet et formel il
n'a rien à voir avec la disparition de
ces deux hommes
à tel point qu'il décide de se taire
lors de sa garde à vue il n'a plus
souhaité répondre aux questions donc il
a gardé le silence jusqu'à la fin
juillet arrive à son terme à vue dure 24
heures maximum donc en accord avec le
parquet de Bourges il est remis en
liberté dans la chambre de la poursuite
de nos investigations
les enquêteurs sont dans l'impasse ils
n'ont rien pour incriminer Claude
juillet
heureusement un nouveau témoignage va
venir relancer l'enquête
le lendemain un homme appelle les
gendarmes depuis quelques jours il a lu
dans la presse locale beaucoup
d'articles sur la disparition de qui et
il pense avoir des révélations
importantes à faire l'homme est gérant
d'une station de lavage auto située à 50
km de couilles et il explique aux
gendarmes avoir été le témoin d'une
scène étonnante quelques jours plus tôt
on lui a entendu parler en fait de la
disparition de deux hommes et il va dire
aux enquêteurs que le dimanche donc 8
mars le lendemain n'a disparition de Luc
Amblard et guy-bordenave il a vu donc
deux individus dont un qui se qui
s'affairait à laver soigneusement un
faux gond blanc qui peut correspondre à
celui de Monsieur juillet et l'autre qui
était avachi donc sur un tas de bois qui
le regardait
[Musique]
le gérant de cette station lavage
constate donc une personne est en train
de laver ce véhicule est de manière très
énergique nous précise que l'individu
nettoyer méticuleusement et l'intérieur
et l'extérieur de son fourgon chose
qu'il a jugé inhabituelle pour ce type
de véhicule voilà l'individu lavé donc
le fourgon pendant 45 minutes chose très
inhabituelle
et l'attitude de ces deux personnages
ayant paru particulièrement suspecte il
note l'immatriculation de ce véhicule et
lorsqu'il se manifeste auprès des
enquêteurs il va tout naturellement
transmettre cette immatriculation les
enquêteurs à partir du témoignage du
gérant la station de lavage
vont faire des vérifications et se
rendre compte que le numéro de
l'immatriculation qui a relevé le gérant
et le même que le fourgon en fait de
Claude juillet d'ailleurs le gérant le
reconnaît formellement sur une photo les
enquêteurs non croient pas leurs yeux ce
témoignage est providentiel il vient
confirmer leur soupçon
elle se demande pourquoi ces deux hommes
ont eu besoin un dimanche matin vers 9h
de nettoyer comme ça de façon aussi
minutieuse ce véhicule il se demande si
les deux hommes en fait n'ont pas n'ont
pas voulu faire disparaître des traces
compromettant à bord de ce fourgon mais
qui est ce deuxième homme et quel est
son lien avec la faire
c'est la propre fille de Claude juillet
qui va alors apporter la réponse
[Musique]
les enquêteurs le savent le dimanche
lendemain de la disparition de Luc
Amblard et Guy Bordenave Claude juillet
avait la garde de sa fille Solène 13 ans
les gendarmes décident donc de
l'auditionner pour savoir si elle aurait
remarqué quelque chose de particulier
et dès le départ le portrait que dresse
Solène de Claude juillet et on ne peut
plus flatteur
il est décrit par tout son entourage
comme serviable comme ne faisant pas
parler de lui travailler voilà il y a
aucune aucune difficulté
dans sa déposition l'adolescente va
ajouter un détail a priori anodin
elle précise que son père l'a ramené le
dimanche soir à La Queue-en-Brie vers
19h30 là où elle vit avec sa mère
or la commune se trouve à seulement 30
minutes de Paris
[Musique]
et souvenez-vous ce même soir à 20h la
carte de Luc en bla a été utilisée pour
retirer 900 euros à un distributeur du
14e arrondissement de Paris
on a deux éléments on sait donc que des
retraits ont été effectués donc sur
Paris
vers 20h20 que Monsieur juillet donc se
trouvait à Paris lui aussi dans les
mêmes temps à partir de là les
enquêteurs vont se dire on s'est
peut-être trompé c'est certainement pas
à Luc Amblard et guy-bordenave qui ont
effectué ces retraits en région
parisienne mais peut-être bien Claude
juillet
le témoignage de Solène est capital
d'autant qu'elle ajoute une information
de poids
la fille de Claude juillet dit mais on
n'était pas tout seul avec mon papa on
était avec un très bon ami de mon père
qui s'appelle Christophe rayé et nous
expliquera notamment que ce Christophe
était présent tout au long du weekend au
domicile de son père
les gendarmes se demandent si le
deuxième homme qui accompagnait Claude
juillet lors du lavage de véhicule n'est
pas Christophe rayé
un nouveau suspect vient donc de faire
son apparition il devient urgent de
l'interroger car cela fait maintenant 10
jours que le couple a disparu et les
espoirs de les retrouver vivant
s'amenuisent de jour en jour
[Musique]
le mardi 31 mars 2009 près de trois
semaines après le début de l'enquête
Christophe rayet est interpellé à son
domicile dans les Landes
l'homme est aussitôt mis en garde à vue
[Musique]
Christophe Raynier est un homme de 39
ans qui est séparé de sa femme avec qui
il a eu deux enfants et dans les Landes
il a vécu de petits boulots
[Musique]
est un ami de longue date de Claude
juillet il se connaissent depuis plus de
15 ans Claudeville à peu près 15 16 ans
de plus que lui c'est le parrain de sa
fille je connais depuis très longtemps
au cours de l'interrogatoire Christophe
Riet semble mal à l'aise et fragile les
gendarmes sentent qu'ils peuvent le
faire craquer il reconnaît donc très
difficilement
avoir été donc en présence donc de
Monsieur juillet au cours du week-end du
7 8 les enquêteurs la scène de question
et il lui demande ce qu'ils ont fait
tous les deux dans la nuit du samedi
dans un premier temps
dans un deuxième temps il dit que le
soir des faits il voit que l'autre
juillet est parti avec une tierce
personne à bord de son fourgon et d'un
seul coup au final il finit par dire bah
en fait la tierce personne bah c'est moi
après un interrogatoire éprouvant de
deux heures l'homme craque et se met à
pleurer il continue à crier son
innocence mais admet connaître une
partie de la vérité et c'est un récit
incroyable que Christophe rayé va livrer
aujourd'hui
commence au début du mois de mars 2009
lorsqu'un jour Claude juillet demande
une bien étrange faveur à Christophe
rayé
alors Christophe a explique que Claude
juillet lui dit qu'il a un problème à
régler avec Luc Amblard et guy-bordenave
donc il a besoin de quelqu'un pour
l'épauler éventuellement pour les
impressionner et que juillet en profite
pour lui dire tu sais qu'il y a
peut-être moyen de se faire de l'argent
voilà moi j'ai envie de j'ai envie de
faire ce casque quelque part et puis bon
on va leur faire un peu peur on va
prendre l'argent et puis voilà la faire
est terminée quoi
Christophe a tout de suite accepté car
il a des problèmes financiers alors vers
20h ce samedi 7 mars 2009 les deux
hommes sont montés dans le fourgon en
direction de quilles ils ont porte avec
eux des armes de fusil et puis d'autres
éléments et notamment des colliers de
serrage
type serflex
et donc il se présente au domicile de
Luc et de Guy qui les attendait
évidemment pas
la porte s'ouvre parce que j'ai Luke
savent très bien qui est Claude juillet
et son copain qu'ils ont déjà en train
aperçu Christophe rayet il rentre à
l'intérieur du domicile les autres n'ont
aucune raison de se méfier qui est Luc
n'ont pas de raison de se méfier
ils discutent pendant pas mal de temps
il boivent quelques verres
tout va bien
mais l'ambiance va vite ton écho car
très vite Claude juillet aurait réclamé
de l'argent au couple
Claude juillet commence à
se montrer effectivement de plus en plus
insistant savoir éventuellement si il y
a de l'argent les comptes bancaires
qu'il faut le rembourser et à partir du
moment où il n'arrive pas à ses fins et
que
luxe se montre pas plus impressionné que
ça l'autre juillet serait sorti du
domicile serait allé au chercher des
fusils au fourgon
monsieur Bordenave qui était encore
assis donc qui est encore assez à table
se lève il s'inquiète il se dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'il me veut avec cette arme
4 juillet va immédiatement lui assainer
un coup de cross au visage pour le
temperer
Guy Bordenave saigne abondamment et
c'est cette tâche de sang que les
gendarmes ont retrouvé donc on se dit
alors donc que ce que Monsieur rayé nous
explique c'est la vérité tout semble
comme un puzzle effectivement se
reconstituer le récit de Christophe Riet
continue et il explique qu'il aurait
menacé Guy et Luke pour obtenir de
l'argent il les aurait même noté
bâillonné
ils ont essayé de découvrir un éventuel
coffre-fort qui aurait pu être sur place
mais visiblement son succès de guerlas
finalement ils ont fait pression sur le
coup pour que ceux-ci se connecte sur
leur ordinateur leur montre leur compte
bancaire et puis leur donne les codes
qui permettent justement de retirer de
l'argent via Internet ou en tout cas via
les cartes bancaire par la suite il est
maintenant minuit et pourtant le
calvaire du couple ne fait que commencer
le coup de cross a fait signer Guy donc
il va falloir quand même le soigner donc
Christophe rayet va aller avec Guy dans
la salle de bain une compresse sur
l'arcade sourcilière qui a beaucoup
signé pour essayer de le soigner ils
sont tous dans la maison
l'un d'entre eux est blessé mais
monsieur juillet donc décide malgré tout
d'attendre le petit jour pour quitter la
résidence
il a peur des contrôles routiers il ne
veut pas se faire contrôler donc il
décide tous les deux
d'attendre 5 heures du matin pour
emmener les victimes
les deux hommes sont conduits dans leur
chambre à coucher
Christophe rayé les installent dans le
lit
pendant ce temps Claude juillet nettoie
les traces de sang et range le désordre
Christophe Riet s'endort jusqu'à ce que
le jour se lève
5 heures du matin on fait monter tout le
monde dans le camion donc Guy et Luc qui
apparemment ne montre aucun signe de
résistance il est monte donc dans le
fourgon partent du domicile du couple
blanc Bordenave de Quick en prenant la
précaution de fermer à clé ce domicile
clé du domicile qui sera retrouvé par la
suite par les gendarmes lors de la
perquisition du fourgon
Claude juillet est au volant de la
camionnette le véhicule quitte le
village de couilles tandis que Guy et
Luc sont ainsi à l'arrière bâillonné et
ligoté et donc les gendarmes se disent
voilà ça y est on a trouvé on va
effectivement arriver à comprendre et
pouvoir retrouver Guy et Luc sauf que
Christophe riait explique que lui
effectivement il est dans le fourgon à
côté de Claude juillet mais que il va
être déposé sur une place à la
Charité-sur-Loire
Claude juillet le dépose et s'en va seul
avec le couple en Blar Bordenave
Christophe rayet insiste alors pour dire
aux gendarmes que son rôle s'arrêtait là
et qu'il ne sait pas du tout ce qu'il
s'est passé par la suite
et lui nous explique que pendant ce
temps-là il a attendu l'ouverture d'un
café
situé à l'entrée de la commune de la
charité et que dans ce café il aurait
acheté des cigarettes et bu à café il
donne une description assez précise du
patron du bar sur le bar il a un peu
plus de mal à donner la description il
indique qu'il y a un comptoir sur la
droite mais qu'il a acheté des
cigarettes qu'il a pris un café qui l'ai
ressorti ensuite du bar qui la continuer
son chemin et qu'il s'est arrêté dans
une boulangerie où il a acheté des
chocolatines ou des croissants et puis
une canette de Coca-Cola le récit de
Christophe Riet est très précis et
détaillé et il n'en a pas fini pour
autant avec sa déposition il apporte une
ultime précision donc on est dimanche
matin il est à peu près 9 heures
monsieur donc juillet récupère donc
monsieur rayé dans les rues de la
charité une demande dans le fourgon et
là il se rend compte que le corps Blair
et guy-bordena ne sont pas là donc ils
demandent à Claude juillet 20 ce qui
s'est passé et là explique une chose
c'est que Claude juillet lui a dit qu'il
les avait emmenés en forêt pour leur
faire peur mais bon qu'il faut pas
s'inquiéter que tout va bien se passer
et qui porteront pas plein de
Christophe Riet explique aux enquêteurs
qu'il ne peut pas leur en dire plus
ce qu'il s'est passé derrière je
l'ignore complètement pour moi très
certainement le couple est encore vivant
en tout cas je ne sais pas ce qui a pu
se passer
Christophe rayé expliquant suite
qu'après être allé à la station de
lavage il aurait jeté par la fenêtre du
fourgon les papiers du couple
puis il serait allé à Paris pour retirer
500 et 400 euros à un distributeur
la déposition de Christophe rayé fini
les enquêteurs sont abasourdes ils ne
savent toujours pas où sont passés Guy
et Luc mais ils ont désormais la
certitude que Claude juillet et
Christophe rayet les ont séquestrés et
enlevés à condition bien sûr que l'homme
est dit la vérité donc face à ce que
nous dit Monsieur rayé on se dit on va
se rendre à la charité on va faire des
investigations on va rechercher un petit
peu les commerces dans lesquels il s'est
rendu et là ça ne colle pas
lors de son interrogatoire Christophe
rayé a fait un plan de la Charité sur
Loire où il désigne précisément les
commerces dans lesquels ils s’est rendu
ce dimanche matin a commencé par la
boulangerie seulement quelques chose
cloche personne ne va affirmer avoir vu
mes siriés ce dimanche matin puis les
enquêteurs se rendent dans le bar ou
Christophe rayet affirme avoir acheté
des cigarettes et pris un café et là
c'est la surprise les vérifications
permettent également de l'établir de
manière formelle l'établissement en
question ce dimanche 8 mars 2009 n'était
pas ouvert et n'est jamais ouvert le
dimanche matin et que ce type
d'établissement ne vend pas de paquet de
cigarettes alors pourquoi Christophe
rayet a-t-il menti que s'est-il
réellement passé ce matin-là
1er avril 2009 Claude juillet est
interpellé une seconde fois à son
domicile il est mis en examen pour
l'enlèvement et là séquestration de Guy
et Lucs
de votre première garde à vue qui a été
interrompu merci de prendre avec vous
quelques affaires et là Claude juillet
prend tout son temps et il va prendre
effectivement beaucoup d'affaires au
grand étonnement des gendarmes qu'il
voit revenir avec les gros sacs et
beaucoup d'affaires de rechange à ce
moment-là Claude juillet semble le
savoir que il est parti pour plusieurs
mois
les enquêteurs lui relatent dans les
moindres détails la déposition de
Christophe rayé mais Claude juillet
reste imperturbable
c'est un taiseux il ne reconnaît rien il
est buté et il n'y était pas il sait pas
de quoi Christophe parle
se retrouve face à un mur d'autant plus
que cet homme a déjà un passé judiciaire
mais c'est un peu comment ça se passe en
garde à vue et donc il fait de la
résistance
mais les gendarmes lui disent qu'ils ont
recueilli des témoignages contre lui le
gérant de la station de lavage par
exemple
et Marie-Laure qu'il l'a vu en
possession des cartes bancaires du
couple et tous ressers un moment donné
hein c'est trop serré donc il se rend
bien compte qu'il a pas d'autres
solutions Claude fini alors par avouer
certains fragments de l'histoire
il admet que Christophe rayé a bien
passé la semaine à son domicile et il
reconnaît qu'ils ont l'avait ensemble le
fourgon blanc le dimanche matin pour le
reste il nie tout en bloc
l'enquête est maintenant au point mort
sans aveu ni preuve matérielle
impossible pour les enquêteurs de savoir
ce qu'il s'est passé et surtout de
retrouver Guy et Luc à ce moment-là
Christophe juillet sont tous les deux en
détention préventives et on ne sait
toujours pas effectivement où est passé
le couple
heureusement pour les policiers
l'enquête va bientôt rebondir grâce à un
nouveau témoin totalement inattendu
[Musique]
mercredi 29 avril le juge d'instruction
Paul Edouard Laloy reçoit une lettre
l'homme qui lui écrit explique qu'il a
été le CO détenu de Christophe rayet et
qu'il a d'importantes révélations à
faire
[Musique]
j'ai fait sa connaissance à l'occasion
de promenade et très rapidement il est
venu à me parler de son affaire il m'a
dit qu'il avait été avec un ami pour
aller récupérer de l'argent chez deux
personnes qui les avaient séquestrées
puis emmener dans un fourgon
[Musique]
le code détenu de Monsieur rayé va faire
état d'éléments
que seul pouvait savoir les parties au
dossier
à un moment où ces éléments-là ne sont
pas connus de la presse et où il n'a pas
d'autres moyens que par Monsieur rayé de
les avoir appris ce qui va intéresser le
jeune instruction masser de peut-être
connaître enfin le dénouement de
l'histoire et le juge ne se trompe pas
l'excodétenu de Christophe rayé va
révéler la tragique vérité
[Musique]
en bordure de la Loire près d'un
supermarché ils ont été tués par balle
et leurs deux cadavres sont enterrés
dans le sable il souhaitait qu'il pleuve
pour effacer les traces
[Musique]
Luc gamblard et
Claude juillet serait le meurtrier et au
minimum Christophe Riet serait le témoin
du crime
et c'est à cause d'une incroyable erreur
que la vérité va finalement éclore
le juge le sait s'il y a bien une
personne qui peut à la fois expliquer
qu'elle a été le rôle de chacun et dire
où sont exactement enterrés des corps
c'est Claude juillet
il a les lettres des détenus il en sait
déjà beaucoup plus
mais il a toujours pas les corps et là
c'est exceptionnel cette interrogatoire
est exceptionnelle gardez la première
question du juge Claude juillet va se
trahir par un simple mot
qui sont guy-bordenave et lucamblard
pour vous
l'un a été mon beau-frère l'autre son
ami
le juge d'un coup s'interrompt et
demande à clôture mais pour une fois
pour cette fois vous vous en parlez à
l'imparfait mais pourquoi sont-ils morts
à ce moment très précis Claude juillet
réalise qu'il n'a plus le choix il doit
dire la vérité
à ce moment-là Claude juillet répond ils
sont morts
réponse intérêt vivant
le 4 juin 2009 au matin trois mois après
la disparition de Guy et Luc les
gendarmes se rendent sur le lieu du
crime indiqué par Claude juillet là où
il a enterré les deux hommes vivants
tout le monde est sur les bords de la
Loire à La Charité-sur-Loire et là ben
Claude juillet va indiquer donc
précisément où les corps ont été
ensevelis
du doigt Claude juillet indique aux
enquêteurs une petite clairière en
retrait du chemin
il semblerait que depuis la végétation
est repoussée pourtant très rapidement
la macabre réalité va éclater qu'on
commence donc à creuser après ces
premières constatations et au bout de
quelques minutes une odeur donc
nauséabonde à Paris immédiatement
on va creuser à peu près sur 30 cm et on
va percevoir déjà les crânes des
victimes quoi les gendarmes creusent
encore et encore mais les corps sont
ensevelis bien plus profondément qu'il
n'y paraît
on met vraiment tout notre cœur à
l'ouvrage et on continue à creuser on
creuse on creuse on creuse pendant des
heures finalement après avoir déblayé
plusieurs dizaines de kilos de terre
c'est une vision d'horreur qui s'offre
aux gendarmes
le couple en blanc bordena va être
retrouvé au moment de la découverte des
corps assis dans le trou en position
l'un face à l'autre
disposer de manière très très symétrique
toujours on voit ça que dans des films
en fait
les corps de Guy et Luc sont dans un
état de décomposition avancée ils ont
donc encore les mains liées l'un comme
l'autre
et des baillons sur les bouches c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment stupéfiant de
voir la barbarie avec lesquels ces deux
hommes ont été tués et
les gendarmes se tournent vers Claude
juillet ils savent que la profondeur
impressionnante de la fosse ne laisse
plus de doute quant à l'après méditation
du crime
[Musique]
pour une ou deux personnes qui creusent
une telle fosse en sachant qu'il faut
sectionner quand même des racines je
pense qu'il faut quand même plusieurs
heures
le plan macabre a été en fait
minutieusement préparé plusieurs jours
auparavant
Claude juillet explique que le lundi
avec Christophe Riet on va repérer les
lieux à La Charité-sur-Loire et que le
mardi c'est le jour où le trou va être
creusé
on passe d'un domicile volontaire à
domicile des volontaires avec
prémicination c'est à dire une
assassinat
Claude juillet explique alors ce qu'il
s'est passé le jour du crime après être
parti de la maison du couple
tout d'abord selon lui Christophe rayet
serait resté à ses côtés tout le temps
alors le fourgon arrive dans la forêt
c'est le petit matin le jour se lève à
peine
Claude juillet Christophe rayet décembre
du fourgon sont armés des fusils et
j'ouvre la porte du fourgon et ils font
descendre les deux victimes qui éluquent
qui sont à ce moment-là Bayonnais et qui
ont les poignées attachés avec du
sherflex
[Musique]
le trou a été creusé à l'abri des
regards dans une petite clairière
menacé par un fusil le couple descend
alors dans la fosse
les deux Guilleux que vont effectivement
être positionnés dans le trou chacun
face à l'autre et puis de la même
manière Claude juillet explique qu'il se
relaient avec une seule paire pour
reboucher ce trou alors que les deux
victimes sont encore vivantes
incrédule les gendarmes écoutent le
récit d'une mort lente aussi inhumaine
que barbare Claude juillet explique
qu'ils ont été conscients tous les deux
jusqu'au bout
qu'il a mis à peu près 1h20 à reboucher
le trou
et que pour que ça aille plus vite à la
fin
il a mis de la terre entre les deux il a
recouvert la première tête puis la
recouvert la seconde tête la dernière
chose qu'ils ont vu c'est l'un en face
de l'autre avec de la terre
qui les recouvrait au fur et à mesure et
avec un regard qui devait certainement
tout dire en fait et qui devait résumer
toute leur vie Lucie c'est un tout
donc
Claude juillet pouvait pas tuer glissant
Luc c'est là le signe de fort de leur
amour finalement puisque jusqu'au bout
ils seront restés ensemble ni l'un ni
l'autre aurait pu abandonner l'autre ça
c'est sûr c'est à dire que Guy Bordenave
était en parfaite santé
s'il avait voulu s'évader ou s'enfuir
peut-être qu'il aurait eu plus de
facilité à s'enfuir que lucamblard qui
était malade et qui était peut-être pas
en bon point or il l'a pas fait puisque
à mon avis il a jamais voulu quitter
l'amour de sa vie
après de tels aveux une question se pose
une seule pourquoi avoir commis un crime
d'une telle cruauté
s'agit-il d'un acte crapuleux homophobe
y a-t-il une autre raison que ne
connaîtrait pas les enquêteurs c'est le
procès qui va désormais de voir
rapporter des réponses
26 septembre 2011 2 ans après les faits
c'est une audience très attendue qui
s'ouvre dans la petite cour d'assise de
Bourges
le procès qui s'ouvre à Bourg j'ai
vraiment exceptionnel puisque on est
face à une affaire ou deux hommes ont
été enterrés vivants on est vraiment
face à une affaire hors norme
dès le début des débats les deux hommes
se rejettent les responsabilités
Claude juillet dit a toujours dit qu'il
a commis c'est fait mais pas tout seul
par contre de l'autre côté Christophe
rayé dit moi j'ai participé dans une
première partie à savoir je dirais
l'enlèvement la séquestration les
retraits d'argent mais moi j'étais pas
du tout présent quand ces personnes ont
été enterré vivante il y a beaucoup de
zones d'ombre ok on n'a pas prouvé le
fait que Christophe Riet ce matin-là
était à la boulangerie ou au café
on n'a pas trouvé le contraire
mais le véritable enjeu du procès est
aussi de comprendre le mobile du crime
la véritable difficulté depuis le début
de cette affaire c'est que après
plusieurs mois c'est ce qui s'est passé
ces deux hommes ont été enterrés vivants
ils étaient conscients l'un et l'autre
on a enterré deux hommes pendant une
heure 20
lentement la raison on la connaît pas
Christophe Riet n'a qu'une raison pour
expliquer son geste
[Musique]
n'a toujours parlé que d'une d'un seul
motif à savoir l'argent
lorsque Claude juillet s'avance à la
barre pour se défendre c'est un coup de
théâtre
contre toute attente l'homme invoque le
crime passionnel
[Musique]
c'est à dire que il a expliqué que Guy
et Luc représentaient depuis toujours un
obstacle à sa relation avec Marie-laure
et qu'il considérait que c'était le
problème et que si le problème était
réglé il n'y aurait plus de problème
dans sa relation de couple avec
Marie-Laure
[Musique]
qu'il aimait Marie-Laure bourdonnave et
que Marie Laure bordona avait métro son
frère c'est ça l'explication n'a pas
d'autre seulement la cour est sceptique
on a du mal à imaginer en fait comment
on a pu en arriver là et pour des
raisons si futile en fait pourquoi pour
des raisons si fut-il on arrive à aller
jusqu'à enterrer vivante deux personnes
lorsqu'on lui demande pourquoi il leur a
pas tiré une balle dans la tête il
explique ça aurait fait du bruit et
lorsqu'on lui demande mais pourquoi ne
pas les avoir à sommet il répond j'y ai
pas pensé
au bout de quatre jours d'audience le
verdict tombe
faute d'avoir pu déterminer
l'implication exacte de chacun la
condamnation et la même pour les deux
hommes
30 ans de réclusion criminelle sans
aucune peine de sûreté un verdict
beaucoup plus clément que les
réquisitions de l'avocat général jugeant
la peine beaucoup trop légère les
familles des victimes sont indignés à
commencer par la soeur de Guy Bordenave
Marie-Laure
t'entends passer parce que nous c'est à
vie qu'on est condamné à vivre sans
notre frère et sans notre beau-frère
nous on est connani nous par contre sans
les voir donc pour moi c'est passé
les deux condamnés ont décidé de ne pas
faire appel
grâce au système de la remise de peine
Christophe rayet peut espérer sortir
d'ici 10 ans
récidiviste au moment des faits Claude
juillet lui ne devrait pas sortir avant
une quinzaine d'années
[Musique]